this video is brought to you by
squarespace the tool to use to make a
website for your brand and grow your
business more about them in a bit
be careful what you wish for you might
just get it this phrase was already
popular in jack johnson's day but it's
doubtful that it had paid attention if
someone had said it to him after all he
never listened to anyone else's advice
it didn't matter that jack johnson was a
black man in america during a time when
that fact subjected him to virulent
racism and discrimination it didn't
matter that people hated him insulting
him or caricatured him in newspapers it
didn't even matter that high-ranking
officials threatened to lock him up or
even have been killed none of that
mattered because jack johnson was
determined to get what he wanted and
nothing and nobody was going to stand in
his way and he got it johnson reached
the pinnacle of the sporting world for
his era becoming for better or worse the
most famous black man in america for two
decades his championship brought with it
great wealth and influence both of which
he enjoyed to the fullest and then just
as suddenly as he'd gotten it he lost it
all the victim of bigotry combined with
his own hubris through it all one thing
became increasingly clear to everyone
around him jack johnson was incapable of
conforming himself to other people's
demands and expectations at all times he
was unapologetically himself and that
eventually
cost him everything
[Music]
arthur john johnson was born on march 31
1878 in galveston texas the year before
union troops had left the south ending
reconstruction and leaving the freed
slaves at the mercy of their former
masters the civil rights of black people
were steadily eroded through the
enactment of a series of black codes or
jim crow laws that ensured that whites
would always be in a perpetual position
of power over blacks but segregation was
not as strictly enforced in galveston as
it was in other places in the former
confederacy a small island off the coast
of mainland texas in the gulf of mexico
galveston was one of the few cities that
the south didn't strictly segregate
white and black neighborhoods at the end
of the 19th century poor people from
both races lived side by side as a
result young jack johnson ran with a
group of friends that included several
white boys johnson believed that he was
destined for great things from an early
age his mother an ex-slave known as tiny
johnson continually told him that he
could do anything he wanted if he wanted
it badly enough and right now what he
wanted was to do anything but end up a
stevedore on the galveston docks at 16
he was already a giant six feet tall six
inches taller than the average american
of the day and like many teenage boys
his thoughts soon turned to sports well
he quickly discovered that he was too
big to be a horse jockey and even for a
thrill seeker like him bicycle racing
was just too dangerous so he settled on
boxing professional boxing had risen
from illicit slugfest held in saloon
basements to one of the most popular
sports in america in the 1890s most
historians consider 1892 to be the
beginning of the modern era in prize
fighting that was when gentleman jim
corbett knocked out james l sullivan the
last of the bear knuckle champions to
become world heavyweight champion boxing
matches were still illegal or heavily
regulated in many parts of the country
but every year it got more and more
popular there was something almost
primal in its popularity for all the
high-minded talk about love of the sport
at its core it was still a desire to see
two men beat each other bloody like
roman gladiators or medieval jousting
matches jack johnson got his start in
boxing by squaring off against fellow
galveston dock workers he was still
young and unschooled in the art of
boxing but he could hit hard and he was
fast on his feet which was enough to
pile up a string of victories over local
opponents he also rode the rails around
the country working in gyms as sparring
partners for professional boxers and
always looking for his big break
that break came in 1902 when he faced
off against a white heavyweight named
jack jeffries in los angeles jefferies
older brother was the legendary james j
jeffries the undefeated heavyweight
champion jim jeffries was in his
brother's corner during the match but
could do nothing to prevent the absolute
beating that jack johnson gave him jack
jeffries's in-ring career was over but
jack johnson's was just taking off he
ratted off a series of victories over
both black and white opponents over the
following years earning more and more
notoriety and money with every match
what made jack johnson such a box office
draw was not only his obvious skill as a
boxer he was a master of what is today
called the science of boxing not only
out hitting but also out thinking his
opponents as well but also his capacity
for showmanship both inside the ring and
out he was flashy wearing brightly
colored clothes and carrying himself
with a kind of cocky self-assuredness
that was rarely seen in black men in
america at the time in the ring he
laughed and taunted his opponents giving
off a carefree appearance to lure them
into making a mistake which he then
brutally punished them for he knew when
he fought against white opponents that
most people were rooting against him and
he didn't care as long as he kept
getting paid he was perfectly happy to
play the role of the heel all the way to
the bank but no matter how good he was
no matter how many victories he had he
couldn't convince jim jeffries to fight
him for the world heavyweight
championship the only reason everyone
knew was because johnson was black while
there was no official rule saying that a
black man was forbidden from challenging
for the title an unspoken gentleman's
agreement dictated that no white
champion should ever risk his belt
against a black opponent jeffrey said
that he would sooner retire and fight a
black man for the title which is what he
ended up doing in 1905 when no more
suitable meaning white challengers
appeared to face him the championship
ended up in the hands of tommy burns a
canadian-born fighter who claimed he
would fight anyone blacks included
provided the money was right but for two
years he found excuses not to meet
johnson in the ring at one point
traveling overseas to box in europe
johnson followed chasing him literally
around the world finally an australian
promoter agreed to pay burns a
guaranteed thirty thousand dollars to
fight johnson in sydney meeting the
champion's obscene demand by contrast
johnson would be paid just five thousand
dollars but the prize he was after was
worth far more to him a shot at the
title let me interrupt this video to
quickly tell you about our longtime
sponsor squarespace now you've heard me
talk about them before and honestly if
you're making a website anywhere else in
2022 well then you're probably just a
bit insane because squarespace have all
the tools you could ever need to do that
in one place and not only that but that
place is super easy to navigate and make
websites on all you got to do is head on
over to squarespace from there the next
step those that want to be quick is to
browse through their extensive selection
of templates they make that super easy
they'll ask you know what's your site
about and you'll say something like
photography and they'll be like well
great here are these photography
templates boom you choose one you
customize it to your own needs you put
your own photos in there your little
description
whatever you can even put a form on
there saying like contact me sign up to
my email list so you can then i don't
know if you're a photographer sell your
photographs or maybe sell your services
plus there's also loads of other
features you can use of course there's
the basics like analytics and blogs but
as already mentioned email lists it's
perfect there really isn't a better
place to build a website go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
to save 10 of your first purchase of a
website or a domain and now back to
today's video
[Music]
december 26 1908 was quite literally
boxing day in sydney australia as jack
johnson faced off against both tommy
burns and a very hostile white crowd for
the world heavyweight championship in
the weeks leading up to the bout
australian newspapers had whipped the
public up into a further proclaiming
burns who up to this point had been
relatively unpopular as the champion of
the white race facing off against a
relentlessly caricatured jack johnson
his quotes were deliberately distorted
in print to make him sound like an
uneducated barely literate man who spoke
in a stereotyped minstrel dialect
cartoons were drawn of him that compared
him unfavorably to a gorilla or a
chimpanzee and some of the tamer slurs
that we used against him were not even
comfortable mentioning here and didn't
bother jank johnson though as he
proceeded to be burned bloody the police
stopped the fight after it became clear
that burns was going to get her to be
kept going and the victory and
championship belonged to johnson the
crowd left in stunned silence some
weeping as a family member had died
johnson though was exultant and so were
the majority of black americans white
americans on the other hand clamored for
johnson to be knocked off its pedestal
and for the title to be restored to its
rightful place the only white man
thought to be capable of besting johnson
was jim jeffries who had so famously
refused to fight him during his reign as
champion initially jeffries was
reluctant he'd been retired for years
now and was overweight and out of shape
but the lure of a big payday as well as
the repeated admonishments for him to
restore the honor of the white man soon
proved too tempting to resist for most
of the year the hype surrounding the
fight between jefferies and johnson
built into an absolute frenzy it was
being billed as the fight of the century
the largest and wealthiest sporting
event the country had ever seen the two
men oh are fighting for the lion's share
of a one hundred thousand dollar purse
hitherto unheard of figure at a time
when the average american worker made
between five hundred dollars and a
thousand dollars in an entire year much
more money was there to be gained from
sales of silent films of the fight and
from promotional opportunities as well
as a lot of gambling for johnson this
was a chance to prove once and for all
that he was the greatest boxer in the
world he personally didn't view the
fight in racial terms he wasn't fighting
on behalf of the black race he was
fighting on behalf of jack johnson but
most people didn't feel that way
especially not white people to them jim
jeffries was the great white hope their
champion to defeat they hated jack
johnson and all that he stood for which
primarily consisted of giving a black
eye to their worldview that whites were
inherently superior to blacks in all
respects originally the fight was
supposed to take place in san francisco
however pressure was put on the governor
of california by an influential
congressman who wanted to stop the fight
to take place they threatened to award
the 9015 world fair to new orleans
instead of san francisco if the fight
went ahead a potential loss of millions
of dollars for the city in the state so
the event was moved across the state
line to the sleepy city of reno nevada
whose governor was more than happy to
receive them reno was a relatively small
desert town of about 10 000 residents a
long way from the casino mecca that it
is today and it was utterly unprepared
for the storm that descended upon it as
the match approached train after train
pulled in carrying fight spectators
roads were clogged with traffic as those
with cars drove them into town reno
quickly ran out of everything food
liquor beds for lodging both fighters
had set up camp in and around reno a
magnet for fans and reporters both over
20 000 people gathered at a hastily
constructed stadium on the 4th of july
1910 to watch the spectacle unfold
thousands more unable to get a ticket
milled around outside across the country
people gathered 30 000 at times square
in new york thousands more outside the
offices of the san francisco examiner
who had arranged for reenactment of the
fight to be played out in a mock ring
above the street they were all waiting
for updates to come in via telegraph the
commercial radio still being a decade
away for all the pre-match hype the
fight itself would probably have been a
little disappointing to a neutral
observer just like the burns fight 18
months earlier jack johnson dominated
his opponent who was outclassed from the
start jefferies was simply too old too
slow too out of shape in the 15th round
after beating jeffries to a bloody pulp
johnson knocked him down twice the third
time he went down his seconds threw in
the towel once again white fans were in
mourning and black fans were overjoyed
and jack johnson was triumphant
white america had disliked jack johnson
before the fight with jim jeffries
allowed they really began to hate him
not only was he a black man better than
any white boxer they put up against him
he was arrogant about it too he knew how
good he was and he wasn't afraid to tell
everyone around him what his skill was
compared to his white opponents his
behavior outside the ring raised
objections from not only whites but some
blacks as well jack johnson didn't
object to racial segregation so much as
pretended that it didn't apply to him
personally he saw no reason why he
shouldn't be treated as the celebrity he
knew he was wherever he went nothing
would keep him from his pleasures as he
called them this primarily consisted of
four things drinking gambling driving
fast cars and women this didn't make him
any different from any other celebrity
or star athlete of the period babe ruth
who had come to be america's most famous
man a decade later engaged in all of
these behaviors but people cheered for
him anyway but a black man behaving this
way was unacceptable to most people and
what was most shocking of all was that
the woman he carried on with tended to
be white miscegenation or the mixing of
the races was one of white america's
greatest fears about black people
interracial marriage was officially
outlawed in 30 states in 1910 and it was
almost unheard of in the states where it
wasn't against the law hundreds of black
men throughout the south were lynched in
the first decade of the 20th century
many of them because of accusations that
they'd been too familiar with white
women when it did happen it was kept a
secret jack johnson by contrast was open
about his affairs with white women and
in february 1911 he legally married etta
derea a devil see from a well-to-do long
island family that turned up their noses
but her new husband etta became
increasingly depressed after news leaked
of marriage she felt isolated as a
family disowned her and her friends
wanted nothing to do with her what was
worse jack seemed utterly incapable or
simply unwilling to be faithful to her
and on at least one occasion he was
known to have hit her she tried multiple
times to take her own life causing her
husband to fear for her safety despite
precautions taken to protect her she
shot herself in their chicago home on
september the 11th 1912. jack johnson
definitely appears to have been
grief-stricken at the death of his wife
but it certainly didn't appear that way
when a month after a funeral johnson
started going out with lucille cameron a
girl had met that summer in the chicago
nightclub the cafe champion they've
probably been sleeping together for
months but now johnson made the
relationship public stating that he
intended to marry her everything
started going wrong after that lucille's
mother unwilling to believe that her 18
year old daughter had been a prostitute
or that she'd willingly fallen in love
with the 34 year old johnson i went to
the police claiming that lucille had
been kidnapped and was being held
against her will the salacious newspaper
story went around claiming johnson was
some kind of crazed sex fiend capable of
hypnotizing hapless white girls so that
they would sleep with him the public was
outraged and demanded johnson be
arrested when lucille refused to support
the charges against johnson she was
jailed and had a sanity question because
obviously a white woman would have to be
insane to believe herself in love with
the black man the past everybody federal
prosecutors stepped in hoping to charge
johnson with violations under the man
act this law passed in 1910 was also
known as the white slavery act making it
illegal to transport women across state
lines for immoral purposes the purpose
of the act was to combat interstate
prostitution which many believed was
exclusively stocked by young white women
forced into it by shady characters often
immigrants or so-called colored people
the moral panic resulted in the closing
down of many vice districts in cities
across the country and would eventually
result in the prohibition of all alcohol
in 1920 but the definition of immoral
purposes was so vague that it could be
applied to almost anything that people
disapproved of like consensual sex
between black men and white women all
they needed was one woman to corroborate
that jack johnson had paid to transport
her across a state line and then engaged
in immorality with her they found it in
belle schreiber one of johnson's many
former jilted lovers who was perfectly
happy to hang her ex-boyfriend out to
dry hell hath no fury indeed despite the
fact that the case against him wouldn't
have stood up under scrutiny in a
legitimate legal setting it should
surprise no one that an all-white jury
convicted johnson of all the charges
against him and sentenced him to a year
and a day in prison johnson defiance at
the end instead chose to flee the
country
alongside his new wife lucille
jack johnson was in exile but he was
still world heavyweight champion he took
full advantage of that living the high
life in europe and making money as he
had been for years in america arranging
exhibitions and performing in vaudeville
shows he also successfully defended his
title belt four times before being
matched up against the latest great
white hope jess willard in havana in
1915. johnson was still as skillful as
ever but the years had caught up to him
and he was no longer interested in
training seriously the way he used to
the way he needed to in order to be a
top fighter 20 rounds into the fight
against willard johnson started to get
tired he was absorbing blows that he
would have blocked earlier in his career
in the 26th round he collapsed knocked
out for the first time since 1901. his
reign was over but his exile wasn't
while will it return to the united
states where the celebration of his
victory over johnson could be best
described as grotesque johnson
crisscrossed the atlantic between europe
and south america eking out an
increasingly meager living now that
world war one was raging and he no
longer held the title of champion in
1920 after seven years as a fugitive
johnson had had enough he wanted to go
home so he agreed to surrender to u.s
marshals at the tijuana border crossing
from mexico he spent his year at prison
in the leavenworth federal penitentiary
in kansas though it wasn't exactly hard
labor his prison duties included looking
after the baseball diamond and
he often had dinner at the warden's
house and he took part in boxing
exhibitions for the entertainment of his
fellow prisoners after being released in
1921 johnson hoped to resume his career
but he was over 40 now considered too
old to be any good as a boxer he engaged
in a series of increasingly sad contests
as the years went by becoming less and
less of a draw with every poor showing
vaudeville was dying by this point too
so his other major skill set was
increasingly outmoded as well the last
two decades of johnson's life went on
like this countless attempts to regain
even a smidgen of his former glory
without success he had few friends left
by this point black america returned on
him a long time ago accusing him of
drawing the wrath of whites down on all
their heads with his foolish behavior in
the case of black boxers at least he
might have had a point the color barrier
was slammed firmly down again following
johnson's defeat as the specter of
another jack johnson was too much for
white people it would be decades before
another black man would be permitted a
shot at boxing's biggest crown when joe
lewis knocked out james j braddock in
1937. lewis's public image was carefully
crafted by his managers so that he
appeared to be everything jack johnson
wasn't where johnson was arrogant lewis
was humble where johnson was flashy
lewis was reserved and perhaps most
importantly of all joe lewis was never
permitted to be photographed with white
women the negative comparisons greatly
embittered johnson and he would spend
the rest of his life denigrating lewis
and dismissing him as a boxer which
earned him even more enmity from black
people who revered louis as their hero
even as he approached 70 years old jack
johnson was still on the road trying to
make money he hadn't saved any cash from
his glory day spending it almost as soon
as he made it on anything that struck
his fancy he also enjoyed driving in
another life johnson professed he might
have become a race car driver instead of
a boxer johnson's driving always
notorious his fines for speeding
probably reached five figures over the
years and he was involved in several
serious crashes always escaping without
serious injury but on june 10 1946 his
luck run out angrily speeding away from
a diner outside of raleigh north
carolina that refused to let him eat
inside he lost control of his lincoln
zephyr and slammed into a telephone pole
he died three hours later in the
hospital
for decades after jack johnson's title
reign ended his name provoked a negative
reaction in boxing circles then 60 years
after johnson knocked out tommy burns a
play called the great white hope debuted
on broadway james l jones won a tony
award for betraying jack jefferson a
thinly veiled fictional portrayal of
jack johnson and his struggles both
inside the ring and out one of the most
enthusiastic viewers of the play and its
1970 film adaptation was champion boxer
muhammad ali who said hey this is a play
about me jack johnson is the original me
it's easy to see the comparison ali like
johnson was a master in ring psychology
getting in his opponent's heads and
forcing them into mistakes he was also
known for his larger-than-life persona
which was full of bombastic speeches
about his talent and his colorful
personality and like johnson ali found
himself persecuted and prosecuted for
his conduct outside of the ring for
johnson it was his interracial
relationships for ali it was his refusal
to be drafted to fight in the vietnam
war and his conversion to islam which
earned him criticism from both the black
and white communities unlike ali though
johnson was never properly vindicated
during his lifetime he would eventually
be given a presidential pardon in 2018
105 years after his man act conviction
still drawing comparisons with someone
who many consider the greatest athlete
of the 20th century
sure isn't half bad although johnson's
reputation has been somewhat
rehabilitated with the aid of modern
hindsight and historical study it's hard
to hold him up as a civil rights pioneer
when he expressed no interest in that
and his behavior seemed to be entirely
self-serving and full of hubris most of
the time he was definitely a complicated
man who didn't really care that much
about what anybody thought of him black
or white but someone shouldn't have to
be a saint in order to be recognized for
their incredible accomplishments despite
overwhelming obstacles and hardships
it's probably best to just dispense with
the hero worship and celebrate jack
johnson for what he was america's first
black sports superstar
warts and all
[Music]
you